yeah i don't know if i'll talk about
them all but i got all sorts of fun
blood draining devices and this one is
for closing mouths
kind of cool hi i'm victor m sweeney and
i'm a licensed funeral director and
mortician and this is
mortician support
[Music]
this is a question from saint severin
question for morticians
when someone dies do you remove their
poo or are we all buried
with an unpoo'd poo
that is such a good question more often
than not your poo is
up to you sometimes you you hear the
myth that everybody uh
poos themselves before they die that's
not always the case sometimes it is
for my purposes when i get someone back
to the funeral home and i'm preparing
them
um if they have pooed then i'll clean
them up
if it's the case that they start pooing
when pressure starts to build up in the
abdomen
then i stop what i'm doing i clean them
up typically what i'll do is i'll
actually
flush out the bowels with the hose
because the last thing you want to have
happen
is someone to start pooing and then they
continue doing it when you can't control
it
jaded never won if a person wearing
contacts dies
does the mortician take them out shower
thoughts
yes historically i've always removed
contact lenses because one of the things
that we need to do
of course is what we call set the
features setting the features would mean
that we
close the mouth and we also need to
close their eyes so we actually have
a device that helps us do this
these are called eye caps they're
essentially spiky
contact lenses that fit over the eyes
and will actually
grip the eyelid when we pull it down
over those little burrs there
i typically remove contact lenses um
because those just get in the way
of me doing what i need to do to set
their features and provide a decent
appearance for the family
question from laney will my cat eat me
when i die
possibly hopefully i think the short
answer to that is yes
i've heard of that happening from
colleagues of mine and as we all know
cats being inferior to dogs they will do
anything they are opportunists
the question from vamp florence how do
morticians not want to chug the
embalming fluid
these look like they taste like fruit
loops well i really love
the picture you have and i noticed
you forgot the blue flavor embalming
fluid is really colorful
but i can assure you it is not tasty it
smells
awful as far as the coloring goes it is
strange isn't it one of the reasons that
a lot of these
fluids are maybe red or other colors is
so that the embalmer
knows what they are without having to
maybe read the label but you'll also
notice that a couple of them are red
when we push the blood out of the body
in arterial embalming we're pushing out
a red fluid
so ideally we want to put a red fluid
back in so we gain access to an artery
typically we'll make an incision maybe
in the neck or in the thigh
and then we'll also gain access to a
vein we open the artery
we are going to have an embalming
machine which acts as a pump and we're
going to use
this arterial tube something like this
so this goes
down the artery and then it's going to
pump fluid through now your vein
we are gonna open with either a large
forceps or this device called a drain
tube so this goes down
the vein and then when we open it
the blood will pour out the side of our
device here and then we can control
how quickly or how slowly we want the
blood to leave the body
when we have a deceased loved one
they're going to look very very pale
because the blood has stopped
circulating so when we put in the the
red blood
the red fluid rather that's actually
going to pink them up in some ways and
make them look a little bit more alive
this is a question from clementine okay
full disclosure
i'm fat and this is a legit question i'm
not trying to be fat phobic but how do
extremely obese people
like i'm talking 400 pounds fit in a
coffin
do they make a plus size coffin or does
a mortician like
cut fat out of them and sew them back up
gonna answer the second part of that
question first
no we do not remove fat and and sew
someone back
up everybody is buried intact if we can
at all help it
so we actually have caskets that are are
made by our manufacturer to be
oversized typically when someone passes
away if they're larger we'll measure
them at their elbows because those tend
to be the parts that stick out the
furthest and then determine
what width of casket we will need to
give them a more comfortable appearance
c for chase do morticians put chapstick
on the bodies or
are they just sitting there casket open
lips cracked out
that's actually a great concern of ours
is drying out not just the lips
but after you die of course your body is
not producing any oils
so your skin can get quite dry we
actually have a
like a heavy face cream that we use on
almost everybody that comes through
in the interim between when they're
embalmed and when we get them ready for
their funeral and put their makeup on if
we need it
we always have that heavy face cream on
to make sure that their lips don't dry
out so as far as chapstick goes i've
never put chapstick on a body but if
someone really wanted me to i guess i
i wouldn't say no here's a question from
coco
now i'm going on google looking up the
weirdest stuff
what do dead bodies smell like dead
bodies
smell awful rotting anything smells
awful we are hardwired to think that
dead human bodies
smell bad and it's a smell you never
forget i myself
i went out to a nice restaurant to have
some aged steak and i couldn't do it
i love this username this is a question
from future corpse
aren't we all what do morticians do with
our organs
after an embalming what happens when
they aren't donated
when we do embalming all your organs
just stay inside your body we can
prepare them all
internally after we finish the arterial
embalming we have what's called the
cavity embalming optimally with the
cavity embalming you're trying to
puncture the lungs
the heart the intestines the stomach
and then you're also going to try to
shoot for the kidneys too we actually
use what's called a trocar and i i have
one here
it's a hollow point spear essentially
and it hooks up to what we call an
aspirator so it's a
it's a vacuum essentially insert this in
the abdomen
and then try to puncture all the hollow
organs and then the vacuum will actually
draw out all those nasty fluids
if you donate your organs typically
organ donations are handled
by organ harvesting companies and they
will actually work with a hospital or
with
me to transport a body where it needs to
go and then they'll harvest the organs
donate them where they need to and then
the body will be returned to me
after that whole process is done
question from paul matthews
do morticians normally just drain the
blood down the sink
the short answer is yes all of our
bodily wastes are disposed
just like our normal bodily wastes the
sewer system
that goes right to the water treatment
plant this is a question from soggy emma
why are coffins so expensive y'all just
bury me raw
well soggy emma that is uh definitely an
option
you can be buried in the ground without
a casket a lot of funeral homes
put substantial markups on their casket
and i think it's just a way to collect
money on on the tail end of a service
but just like a furniture store
which would maybe mark up their kitchen
tables four times what they actually
cost
i would guess that most caskets are
marked up probably one and a half to two
times
what the wholesale cost is this is a
question from tiny rain
do morticians put a bra on you if so
i would like my rotting corpse to not
wear a bra and would like my ghost to be
wandering braless with poking nips
well tiny rain i don't know if there's
much i can do about poking nips
but we do put bras on if the family
requests and the reality is i've
probably put on more bras than i have
taken off in my life
that answer your question this is a
question from
leonard de montague does a mortician
feel just as sad as a normal person
when someone close to them dies the
short answer of that is
yes that was one of the things actually
i myself really worried about when i got
into this profession because at a
certain point
when you see a dead body you almost
always kind of go into work mode
what can i do to help this family what
can i do to prepare
this body so i was very concerned when i
started doing this that maybe i
would start to even think of my own
loved ones as something to help or
something to fix
and not really take in grief like i used
to for my own family for
loved ones my own grandpa passed away
just a few months ago
and i feel just as sad about that as i i
think i ever would
it's just a matter of of perspective and
maybe where you're at
at the moment question from t what
foundation
do funeral directors use to make dead
people look alive
well that's a good question all the
makeup we use is actually
formulated for dead people so it's made
to go
on cold skin as opposed to warm skin
like regular makeup and one of the
things we we try to do
is not cake people with makeup but just
do kind of light layers so that way
their actual skin tone does
shine through a little bit if you've
ever gone to a funeral and maybe you've
seen someone in the casket who is caked
with makeup
they don't really look like themselves
so one of our goals is to tone that down
a little bit
so they do question from lala
approximately how much does a mortician
make
the minimum and the maximum i really
couldn't say
what the minimum and maximum are the
average
i've read in the country is about 65 000
a year and talking to my other friends
and colleagues that seems to be
about the average for my area as well
opia dana
can you get half your body cremated and
the other half buried
do morticians do that asking for a
friend
i have never done that and i've never
had anybody ask
i guess i could see it happening if you
really wanted to you would have to have
a disposition permit that would have
cremation and burial
and i guess we'd probably have to sign a
waiver to uh cut
someone in half but maybe the bigger
question would be
what half are you gonna cremate and what
half do you bury
this is a question from that doodle
bunny how do morticians handle their
jobs
without becoming emotional wrecks that
is a good question
most morticians i know are pretty normal
people there are times where it's
emotional
so you do feel it and there are maybe
days you come home where you just
feel done and you don't want to work or
maybe do what you're
doing anymore but i think the fact that
you can actually help people on
on my side of the desk on this side of
things there are things that you can do
that maybe nobody else can do you can
provide a chance for a mother to
see her son one more time it's those
kind of things that keep you going
in those hard times this question is
from
not waving how do you dress the deceased
i have theories well i would love to
hear what your theories are but really
it's
fairly simple you're just gonna work
their arms through just like you dress a
baby maybe oftentimes if we have someone
maybe very large that we can't move very
well or maybe someone who
has outgrown their clothes or maybe
their clothes are too big will often
time make cuts
down the back and simply drape it over
the front
and tuck it under the back maybe sew it
in a couple places so that way it sits
right on the person
and doesn't look like a like an over
large tent or squeeze them into their
clothes like a sausage
this is a question from trap jason
why don't we bury people vertically
instead of horizontally
they are already dead so why does it
matter we could save so much space
that is a great question i think a lot
of it has to do with practicality
so if you were to bury someone
vertically you'd have to dig pretty deep
hole
and it would have to be pretty narrow
you can imagine how tough it would be
for
let's say six people to carry a casket
to the graveside and then turn it up on
its end and drop
grandma down the hole you might need a
like a seat belt of some kind
question from crowbar jones what does a
mortician do
if are artificial nails on a corpse keep
them
take them off asking for a friend i hope
you don't mean keep them by keeping a
collection
but if you mean keeping them on um more
often than not
i will typically the artificial nails
look nice
clean and of course your nails
underneath are pretty rough if they have
them on i usually keep them
other things that people might be
concerned about removing piercings
they almost always stay if it's an ear
piercing and they have their earrings in
maybe we'll take the earrings out clean
them up a little bit other body
piercings
i always leave them in this is a
question from melody jackson
do morticians take makeup classes when
getting their certifications
yes we do i have a four year degree and
at my college we took courses
on what they call restorative art so
this would include things
like makeup and coloring but it would
also include things
like putting people back together after
accidents
sculpting an ear if someone has lost an
ear lip
boy do morticians also give haircuts
anyone no one that can do a nice fade
yeah
lip boy i do give haircuts every so
often usually only to men
and usually only if it's something minor
if someone does need to get their hair
done we'll actually usually call a
hairdresser in
it's fairly simple because really you're
only working with the
front and the sides of the head this is
a question from
veronica say a body gets exhumed after
two years
what should be the state of the body to
be expected to be
that's one of the interesting things
about my job is that i never actually
know
what happens after burial if we had an
exclamation um you actually have to have
a court order
to open the vault and open the casket
i've heard of cases
where they've opened the casket and the
body looks more or less unchanged and
this was maybe 50 years after the fact
this is a question from jonathan cowep
monty pythons always look on the bright
side of life as the nation's number one
funeral song
what's the oddest funeral music you've
ever heard i haven't
heard too many strange funeral songs
myself but i do have this dream
i have a friend and i told him if he
passes away before i do
i'd really like to sing on eagles wings
but like the swedish chef from the
muppets
it would sound like this you he'd really
initiative
[Music]
relief
[Laughter]
and that's it that's all your questions
i sure enjoyed answering them
and i hope you learned something